il pas m'en servir celui là
des gestes pour soigner des mots pour
réconforter dans un effort un peu plus
supplémentaires d'accord
afin de se déplacer rapidement d'un
logement à l'autre en sillonnant la
ville et la région jessica lobo n'a pas
d'autre choix que de prendre son
véhicule un coup d'oeil aux panneaux et
l'infirmière qui travaille à son compte
avec des collègues comprend que la
facture sera salée recul en attendre
encore 2 euros quand on se retourne
convoi 2 euros on se dit mais on va ce
même pas notre déplacement c'est dur
facile quand on voit qu'on met 20 litres
et pour 50 euros normalement c'est le
plan ya quelques temps c'était mon plan
50 euros là c'est même passé la moitié
l'essence coûtait déjà cher notamment en
raison de fortes taxes dans ce pays très
dépendant des importations de carburant
le bouleversement pétrolier provoqué par
la guerre en ukraine et qui va forcer la
france à diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement et à accélérer sa
transition énergétique n'arrange
évidemment pas les choses
certains achètent que le strict minimum
10 euros 20 euros
donc aujourd'hui je peux faire le plein
c'est quand la dernière fois que vous
avez fait le plein de la voiture
[Musique]
molly devoir payer plus cher ou se
serrer la ceinture
le pouvoir d'achat est l'une des
priorités des grandes préoccupations des
français en pleine campagne
présidentielle et à dix jours du premier
tour de scrutin le gouvernement leur
accorde un petit répit à la pompe
à compter de demain et pendant quatre
mois le prix sera à la baisse de 15 à 18
centimes le litre environ 25 cents
cela s'inscrit dans le plan de
résilience de plusieurs milliards
d'euros présenté mi mars
ce niçois réalise qu'il aurait peut-être
dû attendre rejoint faire le plein 174
euros si je l'avais fait de là j'aurais
gagné 10 euros parce qu'il va y avoir
une baisse à la pompe réduire un peu le
prix de l'essence temporairement dès le
1er avril a surtout l'air d'une mauvaise
blague pour celui ci tous les jours on a
l'impression de se faire voler
comprennent le gasoil comprennent les
sens comprennent qu'on fasse les courses
et tout c'est pareil des taxes de
partout comme d'autres jessica le bo
fait ce constat c'était le prix qu'ils
avaient à la sortie du confinement donc
si je vois pas la différence
l'infirmière devra continuer à faire des
choix moins de vacances par exemple tout
est calculé dans ma vie personnelle
parce qu'il faut que je garde pour la
voix d'europe 1 pour mon travail quoi ça
c'est essentiel pas question de réduire
le nombre de ses visites on a une
dévotion tant qu'infirmière où la
communauté a besoin nous donc on se doit
d'être là et on se doit
on a un rôle à tenir est un devoir à
faire auprès d'eux un métier qu'elle
reste bien déterminé à exercer encore
coûte que coûte on a mis le corps
impeccables babel super ici annick
bureaud radio-canada dans les alpes
maritimes